things are better the world is better
just because there's not a war doesn't
mean there's peace
he's coming some call him apocalypse he
was some kind of God for thousands of
years he's been amassing mutants to take
their powers
he always had four followers like the
four horsemen Eric don't join them
whatever it is you think you saw and me
I buried it with my family together we
will cleanse the earth everything
they've built will fall and the ashes of
them never like this before
it took him present the world needs the
x-men I'm not a hero students with a cop
team if I'm going to teach your kid
something I'm going to teach them how to
fight
haha I'm not afraid of him I need him
he's my father what remember my mom yeah
I know
not all of us can control our powers
then don't
apocalypse means to destroy this world
it's all of us against a god and the
most powerful beings on earth
forget everything you think you know
none of that matters
you're not students anymore I'll take
everything from them
well you've been busy we had a little
help
hey youtubers it's Charlie so new x-men
apocalypse trailer let's break it down
just teasing some of the action of the
film I think this has paced a lot better
than previous trailers the real
surprises the end of the trailer where
it's like we had some help and then you
see Wolverine pop his claws I think we
all expected him to be in the movie but
there really hadn't been anything
official about his participation they've
mostly been focusing on developing the
new Wolverine movie and I'll talk about
this after I talk about x-men apocalypse
stuff so apocalypse trailer picks up
everybody's having a great time it's the
80s it's several years or at least a
couple years after the last movie the
school is doing really well
mystique is much more socialized in this
movie a lot of the damage that we saw
during x-men Days of Future past to her
character has been repaired if you
remember way back to the beginning of
that movie she was basically on this
one-woman mission to free all these
beats she was hardcore
so she's chilled out a little bit and
she and Charles aren't on the outs
anymore but you can tell that she's
still worried about Magneto
so when she says she's worried about him
coming back worried about something
that's gonna be coming she's talking
about Magneto
none of them know about apocalypse yet
it seems like they don't really learn
about him till Jean Grey has her vision
of the future then they go talk to him
we're McTaggart who's like well there's
all these legends about this mythical
figure maybe he's not so mythical maybe
he's an actual person we see apocalypse
taking his ancient technology
this version of the origin story also
looks like it posits that he basically
took most of his abilities from this
alien being or at least this other
mutant if you haven't read the comics
apocalypse is one of the earliest
mutants he's not the very earliest
mutant but he's definitely one of the
first so in the comics he's already born
looking like he looks right here but the
way he gets his celestial armor the way
he gets his ship all the technology that
he uses is slightly different than what
the movie is going with Kang the
Conqueror is a big part of his origin
story in the comics but that's a Marvel
character I think they might have rights
to that character so we'll just have to
wait and see how the movie explains who
this celestial is but we see apocalypse
stealing all his toys and leeching his
abilities like integrating his life
force with his own but if it wasn't
clear he was already a mutant before he
gained all these special toys and I like
the idea that he's stealing powers like
he's stealing the powers of this
celestial being so just really excited
to see this play out there's this heavy
mythology to the film
then there's all like the really fun
x-men moments that you're waiting for
like this really funny moment with
Quicksilver and mystique where he's like
oh yeah magneto he's totally my dad and
she's just like what what the fudge did
you just say
in the comics magneto is quicksilver's
father but they were a coy about that
during Days of Future past they had that
funny joke where he's like yeah my mom
used to hang out with a guy who could
control metal in Michael Fassbender's
reaction is just priceless he looks into
the distance and you see him do the
mental math in his head like does this
kid my said okay well we have a bigger
problem here maybe I'll think about this
later
the way they've explained magneto in
this movie is that he's basically at the
end of his rope like he's completely
lost his faith in humanity and mutant
kind he's walked off the chessboard and
it's just like I can't deal anymore
peace I'm out but apocalypse finds him
and like all cult leaders he's really
charismatic gives a new purpose in
magneto drinks the kool-aid he says his
family has died so they'll probably
address that through quicksilver's
origin story if you haven't seen it in a
while go back and watch first class
where Sebastian Shaw is like this evil
Nazi scientist that just pulls his
abilities out of him I'm gonna shoot
your mother here's some trauma show me
what you can do like just are trying to
get his abilities to manifest but the
movie is an x-men story family is always
a big idea of the x-men they're this big
family that's come together like the
family you choose for yourself versus
the family you're born with so it always
comes back to that like what would you
do to save your family
apocalypse puts together his special
family of four horsemen I really like
the look on Silex face here she's having
so much more fun than everyone else in
this movie right now and I talked a
little bit about her origin story in the
last big trailer video that I did but
her origin story is a little bit like
those of the other four horsemen in the
movie and they've been abused physically
mentally for a long time so they're in
this really weak place so this crazy
cult leader comes along and like shows
them the new way so apocalypse is
preying on people and weak positions
like that so when we see him go around
and collect all these characters you'll
get an inkling of their origin story
like you see angel here fighting in
these pits like he's forced to fight in
this crazy Fight Club here we actually
see there was a picture they released of
him fighting the blob
so the blob is going to be back in this
movie which will be pretty cool but one
of the other big characters I haven't
talked a lot about is Jubilee she's
gonna be part of Xavier school so she'll
be like friends with Jean Grey the
recast version of Cyclops there's a lot
of characters that are from
earlier that they've cast younger
versions of like sophie turner is
playing the new Jean Grey so some of
them you'll totally recognize Jubilee
you might recognize from the animated
series back in the 90s which is a still
a really great cartoon you should go
back and watch it if you have the chance
she was brought into the x-men comics a
long time ago when Kitty Pryde left she
was kind of like a replacement for Kitty
Pryde she was supposed to be like the
young teenage character on the team on
the cartoon series she was more of a
valley girl
so they paired her up with Wolverine a
lot like oh my god I gotta take care of
this kid I don't know how to take care
of kids at all and this is like the most
teenage version of a character you could
ever get so it was just a lot of funny
moments between her and Wolverine but
really big things to get excited about
the new version of storm she's gonna be
badass
can't wait to see them take Jean Grey in
a Dark Phoenix direction I definitely
think that's where the x-men films are
headed up to this towards the Dark
Phoenix saga and just address it I know
a lot of people will be like what are
they gonna cross deadpool over with the
x-men movies not right away i think they
want deadpool to exist in its own small
universe the x-men movies really do
build this universe out they use
deadpool to deconstruct it to make fun
of all the little inconsistencies all
the changes they make the timeline so i
think they want to keep doing that i
think it worked really well so they're
like okay we're not gonna mess with that
formula right away but I definitely
think eventually you'll see Deadpool
with other x-men characters like these
big x-men characters and probably more
when they get to the New Mutants x-force
movies New Mutants is like the next big
movie they've been talking about and I
know Game of Thrones just premiered
Maisie Williams is in talks to join that
they haven't really confirmed anything
but she might end up being the Wolfsbane
character so I just love the idea of her
being a stark dire wolf to Wolfsbane in
an x-men franchise what about the
Wolverine rumors though so I feel like
we're all pretty sure they're gonna be
doing the old man Logan storyline for
the next Wolverine movie it'll be in the
far future so there'll be a little
distance from the events of that movie
in the events of this movie because it's
taking place during the 80s in old man
Logan is like this post-apocalyptic
story like he's lived so long that all
the people he knew have died or turned
into villains surely the big rumor is is
that they're gonna bring the x-23
character in and it's either gonna come
through the Wolverine movie or it's
going to come through the x-men
franchise and after Hugh Jackman fades
off into the distance after he's done
making his
x-men based film player you know playing
The Wolverine character she will fill
that void if you don't know who X 23 is
she's Wolverines daughter she has the
three claws but two of them are in her
hands the third claw on both of her
limbs are on her feet so she can make a
cloth stick out of her feet and - out of
her hands but functionally she has all
the abilities all the powers of
Wolverine but there's a whole bunch of
comic book stuff happening in the movie
when it actually drops there'll be a big
Easter Egg video I'll explain all the
stuff that they did from the comics like
I'm really excited that they're
addressing the idea that magneto is
quicksilver's father and it'll be a lot
of fun to go back and read some of the
old apocalypse stories I'm gonna have to
go back and read some apocalypse comics
but let me know what's your favorite
moment from the trailer there's actually
gonna be a really big month so we have
Captain America coming next week then we
have this movie coming at the end of the
month so May is gonna be a huge month
for really big movies a whole bunch of
really awesome comic-book stuff
happening this week so why you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here for last night's Game of Thrones
episode one video all kinds of crazy
catfishing going on so it was one of the
best episodes ever and you can click
here to learn all about apocalypses
origin story from the comics thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you